when you understand what you're seeing
the most important core value is
everything else becomes so much easier
so for me it's belief my belief is my
single most important core value how
does that help well with every decision
that I make it's seen through the lens
of belief every video content that I
make is about belief it has to be every
interaction I have every Workshop every
book every meeting all of it has to be
run through the belief if I'm hiring
somebody onto my team skills alone
aren't enough it's great that you can
write copies do you believe in
entrepreneur so when you understand your
core value everything else becomes
clearer and you're less likely to follow
what other people want you to do
everybody around you they have a goal
for you even if it's well intentioned
they have opinions on what you should do
with your life everybody around you this
is what you should do with your life
everybody has an opinion you don't know
which way to go if you don't know which
way to go it's because you don't know
what you stand for because you're
standing on quicksand but when you
understand your one word you're who your
most important core value it's like
you're standing on a rock that nobody
can push you from so how do you figure
that out quickly right I mean this is
200 something Pages let's boil it down
super quick for you you want to think
about all the people that you love your
favorite teacher think about your
favorite musician all your favorite
things the thing that when you are
around consuming it reading it being
with them it makes you feel bold alive
amazing confident Unstoppable right
we've all had those moments it's just
not consistent enough yet we're gonna
make it for you and so write down a list
of five to ten things that make you come
alive again people your favorite teacher
movies all of those things that make you
that you love then write down three
keywords that describe each of them why
do I love Seabiscuit the movie because
it's about an oversized jockey and an
undersized horse and an owner that has
no money and all of these things and
they all come together it's believed my
parents taught me that I'm Evan because
Shirley Karma because I can do anything
that I believe that I can it doesn't
have to take you years of work just
write down all of the people and the
things that you love just do it today
it'll make a huge difference in your
life it's worth it this is the best 15
minutes you can spend in your life do it
pause the video and do it and then just
see what comes up consistently what word
comes up over and over and over and over
and over and over again chances are
that's your one word that's your who me
motivation what top 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Nina Carmichael and we
made these videos because you're
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know if you're
capable of more and you get that Push by
surround yourself with the best so today
let's learn from one of the best my
husband Evan Carmichael his top 10 rules
for scissors
rule number two trust your ideas the
reason most people don't win isn't
because you don't have great ideas
you're a genius the only thing missing
is momentum you're dreaming huge that's
amazing I love it but there is zero
momentum it's never going to be the
right time and nobody is coming to save
you the time is now to make your dreams
happen so here's a really fun example
yesterday I needed to take a break from
my work to go to the bathroom so go to
the bathroom open up my Feedly and start
looking at you know some of the new
stories that were happening and there
was this amazing video that I saw about
a busker in Toronto who a company
organized what they call the cash mob
instead of a flash mob they would all
show up at this guy doing his you know
guitar singing plane and just throw
money at him not at him but in the
guitar case right and they were they
probably made like a thousand bucks
they're throwing 20s and 50s Not Just
pennies and in you know dollar bills and
stuff but giving them tons of money and
and it and he's starting to get
overwhelmed he's playing the guitar he's
getting overwhelmed and and I'm I'm
getting motivated and excited and just
heartfelt what a great moment and I
decide in that moment we need to make
this video more public we need to spread
it this has to go up on the channel I
need to spread awareness I want to I
want to promote this company who put
this together I love it what a great
idea
and so right away like here's the thing
you get a great idea trust your good
ideas go do something about it I could
have easily filed that away next week
I'll work on it and then what guess
what's going to happen next week I'm not
going to work on it because I'm going to
move on to something else right I'm in
the middle of my day I've got priorities
and a plan for that day and then this
thing pops up I trust that idea trust
that it's great and that I gotta do
something about it because if I'm
inspired if you're inspired you're going
to create gold you're going to create
Magic
if you're not inspired then just keep
doing the work that you're doing
hopefully it's not depressing and
negative it's just you're creating it's
amazing you're in your flow but when
something new comes up that you're super
excited about I think you need to follow
that through and so I I parked a little
chunk of my day yesterday to then make
that video and I made the ending and I
made the thumbnail and I made the
description and I made the title and I
created it all in one shot and I sent it
off to my editor Christina we love you
Christina say hey we got to put this up
on the channel find the time this is not
scheduled in my usual content calendar
but let's find a time put it up right
and that maybe took I don't know half an
hour
it took half an hour out of my day that
I was supposed to do other stuff to make
that happen because momentum matters
momentum matters it's the most important
thing you're a genius the ideas that you
have are goal they're genius you're just
not doing enough with it rule number
three explore success is the progressive
realization of a worthy ideal what I
took away most from that definition is
the word Progressive you want progress
you want to learn you want to keep
growing what was once a challenge for
you is now simple and it's very easy to
fall into a routine that once served you
but is now limiting you the day you stop
progressing is the day that you start to
hate your life and it can be sneaky it
could sneak up on you without you even
noticing what happened so I was trying
to think of a personal story to share
with you about this and I realize it's
been more than 10 years since I've
actually felt that I felt that I've
stopped progressing that that I started
to hate what I was doing it's been over
10 years it was basically since I
started on YouTube and I'm going to
share with you the the hacks that I use
so that you won't fall into that rut but
what happened for me 10 years ago was I
built my website right I sold my
business I had success I was speaking
around the world I started building my
website
and I built it into a giant platform we
had a hundred thousand plus pages of
content making money from advertising
and I just stopped liking the business
it started to feel like we're putting
out content we're putting out articles
just trying to make money putting out
articles that that I didn't always
believe 100 in we had a bunch of guest
people writing content right we had four
or five thousand authors for the website
and not all of their opinions or views
or mindset or voice
reflected my own and I just stopped
liking the business it was a successful
business making money building a team I
had eight people I think at that time
and I decided you know what I this isn't
this isn't I'm losing the love for this
I need to try new things and I started
making YouTube videos it was one
experiment I probably did a bunch of
different things but YouTube was one
experiment that I sucked at but I loved
and I kept coming back to and and it
taught me it taught me a lesson it
taught me that you need to explore this
this is what I tell a lot of people when
they're entrepreneurs I had a woman uh
Melissa who joined me on an IG live the
other day and she's talking about how
she's got a real estate business that's
making her money but she wants to be a
speaker and the speaking business is
growing I can't support her fully yet
but the real estate business gives her a
lot of money she said well I like doing
both
like well no you don't
right like in five years where do you
want to be you want to still be doing
real estate no no five years I don't
want to be doing that I want to be doing
the speaking thing great that's we need
to start spending more of your time it
doesn't mean quit the job it doesn't
mean stop doing real estate or stop
doing the thing that you're just okay
with but while you still have one foot
in it you have to explore you have to
try you have to taste you got to see
what else you can do spend one day a
week two days a week depending on your
financial situation is my advice to her
spend one day or two days a week
focusing on the speaking business so
that in six months you can be out of the
real estate business and being speaking
full-time and then do anything you love
right if you just like it
that should be a warning sign to get out
not ASAP but you need to start exploring
but so many people end up hating the
thing they're doing so many
entrepreneurs start a business they love
it it's challenging it's exciting it's
exhilarating and then they found that
they bought themselves a job and they
actually hate their business and then it
becomes too late to get out because you
can't find the person to sell it to or
you just have to walk away from it
but so many people just like it and
you're not exploring enough to chase
down the opportunity rule number four
have a mission you don't win a Nobel
Prize by telling yourself that you want
to win a Nobel Prize you win a Nobel
Prize by having a mission so big that it
forces you to become somebody new a
stronger more bold more resilient
version of you if you make success your
goal you will most likely miss it
because you have the wrong outcome in
mind make impact your goal make your
mission your goal and you'll end up
having more success than you ever
thought possible I look at my YouTube
channel as an example and the next goal
would be to have 10 million subscribers
right I got my hundred thousand plaque I
got three of them there I got my million
plaque
the next goal is 10 million and there's
nothing wrong with having goals but the
problem is if I made 10 million the
thing like all I'm doing is chasing down
10 million subscribers it forces you to
do short-term decisions that end up not
serving you right if I wanted to just
blow up my channel the best way to do it
isn't actually to spread positive
content negativity spreads much faster
than positivity if I made a top 10 video
on why this person's soccer and
expressive about how this person's an
idiot or people fighting people can't
help but see that people that's why
people stop to see the car accident on
the highway right we don't reward the
good drivers you want to see the chaos
you want to see what caused the flame
there's a fight on a street corner
you've stopped to see what's going on
right we're attracted to the negativity
more than the positivity that's a faster
way to blow up my channel the problem is
I wouldn't feel good about it
I don't want to spread negativity I
don't want to spread conflict and Chaos
I don't want to spread pessimism I don't
want to spread uh despair I don't want
to spread ego I don't want to spread
negativity I just I don't want to do
that and so it would lead to me flaming
out before I ever hit the goal that's
the problem you can have this goal this
is what most people do you have some
goal here's my goal I'm going to do
whatever it takes to get to that goal
the problem is you won't do whatever it
takes because it's going to get too hard
you can only do things for so long that
you don't love before you quit and give
up and so there's nothing wrong with
having a goal but more important than
the goal is the mission I want to solve
the world's biggest problem is something
that's never going to happen never in my
lifetime it's never going to happen I
want people to believe in themselves
more it's never going to hit that
ultimate goal where everybody is Michael
Jordan at something it will never happen
and I wake up every day trying to do
that and so if you make a goal
tied to some outcome like getting 10
million subscribers on YouTube it's
going to force you down a path that
likely won't serve you so you leave with
a mission you leave with the impact and
success will fall also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five Raise your
standards the difference in people is
their standards the world is full of
people who started with less than what
you already have right now and they're
winning and too many people are out
there complaining complaining that you
don't have the money that you don't have
the time that you don't have the
experience that you don't have the
personality for it all legitimate
logical reasons but others have done it
with those very same circumstances as
you with worse circumstances than you
the difference is they have a higher
standard for themselves and today we're
going to raise yours one of the things
I'm most proud about for myself why do I
love Evan Carmichael is because when I
say I'm gonna do something I do it
especially when it gets hard like it
doesn't count until it gets hard and I'm
doing it not just for other people I'm
doing it and that's because I promise
you that I would show up I'm doing it
for myself because I said I was going to
do something and then I go off and do it
this is the foundation of self-esteem a
self-confidence of self-love doing it
when you say you're gonna do it and so
on Monday I usually have a two-hour
walking meeting without Alex helps him
run trying to dance salsa he comes over
Monday's my mentoring day and we'll
usually go for a two-hour walk around
the city and it's starting to get cold
you know it's winter time here it's
getting cold and so we bundle up and we
go for our two-hour walk while we while
we talk and while we meet I'm trying to
do walking meetings more just for my own
health and and just because just for the
challenge of it because it's easy to
start something like that in the spring
or in the summer it's really hard to do
it when it's in the winter and you live
in Toronto Canada and it's snowing and
cold right so this Monday Alex was sick
he still came in he was sick he was
running a bit of a fever not crazy sick
but just sick and Nina my wife super
caring said hey maybe you shouldn't go
for a walk outside and and my heart just
like come on no we have to I said I was
gonna do it right I have to I have to
for myself I have to go on the walk like
I'll go on the walk and leave Alex at my
place and and just film the meeting with
him uh but we came up with a different
solution which was I have a I live in a
condom we have a gym in my condo and we
went down to the condo gym and I walked
on the treadmill while he stood or sat
next to me for two hours because I said
that I was gonna do it how important is
that one two hour walk not much right in
itself not much am I gonna get healthy
from doing that one walk no am I gonna
lose weight by doing that one walk no
I'm gonna have so much more mental
Clarity by doing that one walk of course
not
but it's the whole game because you're
teaching yourself that you follow
through you're teaching yourself that
you have high standards you're teaching
yourself that when you say you're gonna
do something you follow through because
life is coming for you with a ton of
roadblocks life is going to throw tons
of curve balls at you if you can only do
the thing that you said you were gonna
do when it's easy and the path is
perfectly clear you're never gonna do it
this is why people don't stay consistent
because as soon as life gets hard you
let yourself off the hook you allow your
standards to drop to say oh it's okay
yeah of course I can't go for a while
because Alex is sick
right and there are definitely
legitimate times when you should let
yourself off the hook if I was dying in
bed with a fever and I couldn't get out
of bed I wouldn't go for the walk that
makes sense don't be stupid there's
times where you need to be gentle on
yourself but more often than not we are
too gentle in ourselves when we
shouldn't be I could have done the walk
and we did it we did it in the in the in
the gym downstairs and Alex stood next
to me and sat next to me and didn't have
to go outside and and get the cold on
him and I still got my walk-in right and
I feel great about it
because I did it when it was hard
because here's this obstacle that life's
throwing at me here's an easy way when
everybody around me is saying you don't
have to go off and do it and a little
tiny voice inside my own head saying
okay well here's a chance you don't have
to do it like no be quiet voice I'm
doing it we're finding a solution let's
go and the solution is gonna walk on the
treadmill downstairs rule number six be
more productive what matters is that
you're productive that you get results
that you stop wasting time too many
people default to thinking that if they
just wake up an hour earlier they're
going to be way more productive if
you're not productive in a 16 hour day
what makes you think that you're gonna
be more productive in a 17 hour day when
you have less sleep so this is a
interesting message in timing for me
right now because I I love beating the
Sun up I love it I I love working I like
it's my default state of Nina is off on
a Friday night with her friends or
something 80 chance I'm working I love
it I look forward to it when I go close
my eyes I can't wait for it to be the
next day okay like I'm pumped to go off
and do the work I recently did a sleep
study and my doctor was concerned I
wasn't getting enough quality sleep so I
wanted to do a sleep study and the
doctor after going through the results
told me that I need to be sleeping eight
and a half hours to nine hours a night
and it and it like
super disappointed me eight and a half
hours to nine hours are you kidding me I
I'm trying to go from I was trying to go
from eight to seven I was waking up
after eight hours sleep and and feeling
still a little bit tired and so that's
why my doctor recommended even going to
the sleep study and I'm trying to figure
out how do I hack it to get down to
seven and still be fully functional not
not be you know lazy and slow and not
having my cognition and uh yeah he said
I need to be sleeping eight and a half
to nine hours a night he said is that is
that normal like are you not worried
like no as long as you're under 10 it's
normal people range from six to ten and
they're totally fine like this sucks I
mean I'm not happy about it I'm still
looking at how can I hack my sleep more
and we've tried a lot I have the chili
pad we've got you know meditation before
sleeping I'm lying on the bed of nails
with the thing behind me the pillow the
nail pillow uh no you know phones or
computers x amount of time before going
to bed red light filters on everything
red lights no lights at all in the place
right like just these real red lights
going around after Sunrise after Sunset
lots of it cool down the temperature I
don't know all of it don't eat past
eight o'clock no caffeine past two
o'clock all of it I'm doing all of that
stuff all of it right plus probably a
lot more stuff I've I've studied and
hacked away I still believe there's a
lot more hacking I still want to get it
from nine to seven but but if I'm at
nine and I need nine I think you should
get nine I'm at the point now where if I
wake up and the Sun is still uh not up I
stay in bed and and that's actually uh
boosting of confidence it's like okay so
I wake up and sun is hasn't come up yet
okay this is hard this is difficult it's
difficult for me to not get out of bed
I'm gonna stay in bed just because now
I'm I'm a I'm a weird duck so maybe this
works for you maybe it doesn't but I was
having a great conversation with uh
Jeremy who's on my team who I've
invested in his business he's helping
companies scale their YouTube channels
and he was going through the same thing
where he was feeling a little tired in
the afternoon he wanted to nap on some
afternoons and that's never been me so
dude you need to just try uh waking up
without an alarm
and normally he's up at 4 30 in the
morning or something
um so just wake up without an alarm and
see how it goes and he ended up sleeping
for nine hours and hating hating himself
for doing it it's like dude maybe you
need nine hours like much more important
than that extra hour or two is what are
you doing during the day if if you're
losing energy during the day and you
want to nap every afternoon you're not
being productive like there's no way
sleep and be productive you need sleep
to win I think everybody should get a
sleep test I think it's a brutal
experience you don't you barely sleep
right when you're there you got to stuff
up your nose and a million sensors all
over you but to know how much sleep you
actually need and making sure that
you're productive during the time that
you are awake that's the most important
thing that you are productive during the
time that you're awake is way more
important than if you wake up before the
sun gets up rule number seven get used
to rejections if you are doing something
new you are going to get rejected if
you're doing something that you're not
good at yet you are going to get
rejected if you're doing something that
goes against the status quo you are
going to get rejected so you have two
choices live a life with zero growth and
never get rejected or chase your dream
deal with the rejection that comes and
go change the world I have rejection all
the time in my life from Little
rejections of making videos that don't
pop to bigger rejections of projects
that I care deeply about that just don't
fly and people don't accept at the
beginning I look I look at this built to
serve this is a great example built to
serve is my new book this book
I'm insanely proud of
I think it's life-changing I mean it
should be I think the work that you
create should be life-changing but I
poured so much into this and I think
people need to read it like I I
desperately think that this book will
change a lot of people's lives it could
change your life I believe it's not just
hyperbole like I I truly fundamentally
believe him when I came up with the idea
I was on my tour earlier this year and I
did not have time to write it right I
was on my tour I'm behind on everything
a million things being thrown at me
meeting people doing my events seeing
the cities and it just I just decided I
had to write this book because of all
the feedback I was getting from people
it was all the one-on-ones I was doing
with people the same questions kept
coming up how do I find my purpose how
do I know who I am how do I turn into a
business and so that's the that's the
point of the book figuring out what your
purpose is and how to use that to then
serve the world right it's called built
to serve
and make it into a business so you can
make money doing it and build a team and
go off and live your mission when I
first pitched my publisher on it they
didn't want it they didn't want my book
right so uh your one word is down here
that's with penguin random house and
penguin passed so they had first my
first deal with uh penguin Random House
typically how they'll do deals
especially with first-time authors is
you get you get a deal and then they
have the right of first refusal in your
next book so as soon as I get my next
book they get the right to look at it
first before I give it to anybody else
right so that's why I signed it's like
okay here we go let's go it's a perfect
fit I mean it follows really nicely with
your one word
let's go right and they said uh no we're
gonna pass like yeah what how do you PR
this is better than your one word I mean
I love your one word it's great
this is the whole thing how do you pass
on this
um let's just
and we had to wait because it's 30 days
and all these anyway legal stuff
um so then we started looking at other
companies we started looking at other
publishing houses and there were other
ones that seemed to line up really well
with the content that they had the the
the author lineup that they have and
almost everybody everybody except the
last one right uh said no
and I mean like I gotta I got a big
YouTube channel we have momentum we
already have our first book where like
why why and all sorts of different
reasons you know
um just not not doing personal
development books anymore not whatever
uh nobody came out and said like we hate
you Evan so maybe hopefully that's not
the reason
um and then we found one that that
picked it up I was like okay
let's go and if if that one didn't pick
it up then then we would have kept
looking for more Publishers or I would
have just made it myself
just self-publish it put it out right
what do you do when the people around
you don't accept what you have when you
want to take something in a New
Direction I could have done something
else I could have done something easier
if I just did a book about Jack ma right
in his room for Success that would be
easier to pick up than this which I talk
about on the channel but it's not the
main thesis of the channel but that's
what I want to make and that's what I'm
going to make whether it's I get a
publisher or we're gonna you know create
it myself it's gonna be birthed into
existence because I decided so and just
taking that mindset and approach and you
have to if you love the thing if you're
doing something different
then you have to keep going when people
say that I don't want to pick it up that
it sucks that it's stupid that you're
maybe it's even a great idea but you're
not the person who's gonna do it right
you have to keep going and Rule Number
Eight be your biggest fan and critic I
think judging yourself is actually great
I think you need it I think it's healthy
I think people should be harder on
themselves the problem is people can't
handle being even a little bit harder on
themselves because they're already at
the point of being depressed or even
suicidal the secret starts with
self-love your self-love has to equal
your self-criticism you have to be your
biggest fan as well as your biggest
critic the root problem isn't judging
yourself it's not loving yourself one of
the challenges to think of being human
is we are social animals we're social
creatures we rely on each other we need
each other we want to belong we want to
be part of tribes we want to do things
together right we want to be around
other people
so that makes us want to fit in and that
makes us play small worry about what
people think about us because if we
don't do the thing that they want us to
do they might judge us and kick us out
of the tribe the good news is there's so
many different tribes you can do now
right there's so many different people
that it may not be your friends that you
have right now may not be your parents
or your family or your community right
now but whatever you want to do there is
a group of people who believe the same
things you believe we think the same way
you think and I think one of the
healthiest things you can do is whenever
you feel the eyes of potential judgment
for something that you want to do you
have to go up and do it just to show
yourself rule number nine kick yourself
forward comparison other
I think it helps you I think it serves
you the problem is most people look at
other people start feeling insecure and
then kick themselves down the key is to
kick yourself forward not down but you
need that kick otherwise you stay where
you are this is one of the reasons why I
love modeling success why I created all
my YouTube channels and all the content
that I've done and I have the people
behind me on the wall because I love
looking at other people I love learning
from other people I love seeing somebody
do amazing things and say that's what's
possible this is what's possible I look
at Les Brown as an example and I think
he's the greatest speaker of all time at
least that I've I've seen I don't maybe
maybe the ancient Greeks were better I
don't know but but Les Brown modern era
on video I think is the greatest speaker
and
I look at that and say that's what's
possible not that I can't do that here's
what most people do they look at Les
Brown and say well I can't do that
and then they start feeling insecure and
I'm just I'm just an imposter trying to
be like that now and then they quit
and then they feel they feel low with
self-esteem when they and they beat
themselves up over because they're not
less brown
I look at last Friday that's what's
possible this is what this is what
humans can actually accomplish and
Achieve I want some of that I want to
get better I want to drive and improve
not to be the next less ground but be
the best me but this is what's possible
I look at David Goggins Man David
Goggins look he came out of nowhere who
was David Goggins did you guys know
David Goggins five years ago no he blew
up out of nowhere because of the passion
and intensity and truth of his message
right I love that and it's easy to say
and look at that say well look at how
passionate David Goggins is and look how
he blew up I could never do that
I'm not as strong as him I'm not as
crazy as him I don't have the same
mindset as him and so I can't do that
and you compare yourself to Goggins and
then you say well I can't I can't and so
you don't start that's the problem
you should look at Goggins and say look
at what's possible you could come from
nowhere nobody knowing who you are and
in a short amount of time blow up
because you have a message that matters
you can look at how passionate he is
about his message every video he's got
insane passion right this guy he's not
going to give you nice hugs and
compliments but he he cares about his
message right you can see that and you
could take that as what's possible you
can you can care deeply about your
message too and model David Goggins and
and apply that to make your message
stronger and better I think if you just
were competing with yourself I think
you're actually gonna suck
I think I think if you're the best at
something and you don't have any
competition I think you actually suck uh
being the big fish in a small pond
actually limits a lot of creativity uh
limits your ability to go off and Crush
things I think I think it is I think
when you even even in animals when you
see animals going up against each other
in a race
when when somebody's close you work a
little bit harder right I think I think
we need that in our ecosystem the key
though again is to make sure you're
kicking yourself forward to say this is
what is possible not this person so much
better than me I suck feeling insecure
feeling depressed you need the kick just
make sure you're kicking yourself
forward not down at rule number 10 10
ability
it may not be your fault but it's your
responsibility it's not your fault that
you were born broke but it's your
responsibility to fix it it's not your
fault that you had no education but it's
your responsibility to learn it it's not
your fault that you had no connections
but it's your responsibility to make
them it may not be your fault but it's
your responsibility and the sooner you
accept that the sooner you're gonna win
so I recently posted to my YouTube
Community tab a quote about momentum I
think people don't have momentum and I
think the path to get momentum is to do
work for free for ideal clients until
you can prove your value and then they
pay you so here's what I wrote I wrote
If you have no momentum no traction no
clients and start for free prove your
worth and build momentum give them
something they can't wait to have again
and pay for this time hashtag believe
and every time I write there's always
tons of great positive feedback but but
this time somebody wrote a kind of
negative comment and so I wanted to read
it because it's highly applicable in
this video he said Kitsch I don't know
about some of your advice everything is
my fault and work for free to which I
reply yes when you Embrace those two
you'll start questioning your goals it's
a hard message to to take on right
whether everything is your fault
everything is your responsibility where
you are right now it's not about beating
yourself up it's not about saying I suck
and I can't get out it's saying listen
this is what happened to me that's the
past the past doesn't have to equal to
the Future everything that I was born
into and and the circumstances that I
grew up with they don't have to be where
I go going forward look at all your
Heroes look at the people who've made
huge inroads change the world the people
that you look up to and aspire to be
like very few of them were born super
wealthy most of them had a worse
upbringing than you did and they could
make it so why can't you you're just
locked in your story too many people are
locked into their story they're not
taking responsibility they're not saying
this is my my problem to get out of
I wasn't put here right you've been
drafted into a war that you did not
start you were put here
and you have to survive and then you
have to learn to thrive and it's that
decision that you are in charge that
you're responsible that if you go to the
mirror and you say why am I not
achieving my goals why am I not further
ahead
as long as you're blaming somebody else
that might keep you comfortable
keeps you comfortable it means you don't
have to do anything right you're not
winning because your mom you know hit
you you're not winning because your dad
never supported you right you're not
winning because the school system sucks
as long as it's somebody else to blame
it's it's comforting and everybody else
around us are doing the same thing
nobody's taking accountability
everybody's saying it's somebody else's
fault right of course it's not your
fault that you're losing because then
you have to do something about it and
even if you're not losing you're not
hitting the goals as hard as you should
and it's so much easier to put the blame
on somebody else and say well
it's that person's fault or really it's
a person in the mirror it's you it's me
I am not further ahead in my business on
my YouTube channel not because of the
YouTube algorithm
not because my team didn't deliver the
Right video on time me I'm the problem
it's my fault it's my responsibility
right I have to go fix it I created this
mess it's not a mess it's amazing but
I'm not a 10 million subscribers
because of me
it's not that people don't want to watch
the content and people don't want to be
inspired
it's me I need to get better I need to
improve and and even if it wasn't my
fault just taking that on
gives you hope that you can change it as
soon as you start putting not even the
blame I think blame is not I don't think
blame helps I don't care who's to who to
blame I care how do we fix it right if
there's a problem that happens in my
business not like who's screwed up I
don't care who screwed up I care what
are we gonna do to make sure that we can
get out of this hole and then it doesn't
happen again the next time right taking
personal accountability for where you're
at if you have not hit your goals this
is good news you can
but nobody's coming to save you
nothing's gonna magically change around
you you you're the change you will make
the change you can go make it happen
if I want to grow my business bigger I
need to accept that I need to grow
bigger me personally Evan Carmichael I
is my fault is my responsibility I am to
blame
and use that as a kick forward to say
great like at the beginning that may
suck say oh man I've wasted how many you
know weeks months years going down the
wrong path just casting
blame on other people realizing now it's
my fault okay what can you do about it
now you can change it like at the start
the reality the realization sucks but
then it's also the greatest thing of all
time if you're coming out of
from under the Rock and realize oh my
God this is all my fault
that gives you the power to fix it
because as long as you're relying on
somebody else to do something and they
don't show up you can constantly blame
them but you're never growing you never
accomplish anything because you're
waiting for that you have to wait for
anybody
it's just you and you can fix it you
have the strength you have the power
you're Michael Jordan you have the
abilities you have the skill set and if
you don't have it yet you can develop it
you can acquire it because your Heroes
did it and you can too
burnout is real but I think most burnout
happens because people are not doing the
thing that they actually love doing it's
not just about being busy and keeping
your mind occupied all day you can be
busy and hate your life and get burnt
out if I was an accountant I would hate
my life and burn out in a day because I
don't like being an accountant but doing
this thing that I love I put in way more
effort way more work and I love it it's
been 10 plus years of still having my
YouTube channel and I'm not burnt out if
anything I'm pushing harder than ever
before because I love it and so I think
it's not just about being busy it's
about being busy on the thing that is
your mission for life now compassion
fatigue is a thing doing it so much that
you burn out yourself is possible but
again that is not why most people are
burning out most people I believe are
burning out because they're spending too
much time too much energy too much
effort doing things that they hate and
if you wake up and hate your life and
hate the job you're about to go to then
just no wonder why you feel like you're
burning out so I recently came back from
going to Tony Robbins event in Dallas he
invited me to sit in the front row and
uh super blessed and grateful to have
Tony support and I went there with Alex
friend of the channel who helps me run
trying to dance salsa and we're on a
super crunch timeline because Alex was
teaching classes the the evening before
we left and then the day of the last
event and we we rushed down there Alex
was flying in just to get to the event
he's late on the first day we're rushing
to leave on the last day and it's
non-stop if you if you've been to a Tony
Robbins event it's it's all day all
night it's eight in the morning to
midnight and then up again the next day
and doing the same thing and and it's
wild and it's fun it's amazing and my
favorite thing to do whenever I travel
is actually meet believe Nation meet you
guys and so all through the event I wear
my believe hoodie and I'm not wearing
Grand stuff I'm wearing Evan Carmichael
stuff with the plane and the believe on
the back and people are stopping me and
that's actually the best it doesn't take
away from my experience Tony's often on
stage at the top at the beginning of
every event saying hey I have some
friends of mine you might know them
don't be celebrities leave them alone
don't talk to them let them have their
own experience and it always makes me
sad when he says that because for me
meeting you guys meeting people who
recognize me and that's a group that I
over index because people who watch Tony
videos you know they're probably going
to find my content I like it I like it
more when people come and say hi it adds
to the experience for me and then on the
last day before we rushed out to go to
the airport I set up a meet-up right I
had an hour open before having to get to
the airport so let's do a meet up let's
do a local Dallas Richardson Texas
Meetup right and and it could have spent
the time doing something else or
sleeping in or writing my book or doing
anything else but
it's not burnout from you like that
fuels me that gives me more energy I
love it hanging out with believe Nation
gives me more energy than it takes away
and I then took an Uber to get to my to
the airport and the guy who drove the
Uber was actually in the the Meetup in
Richardson's like I gotta leave early
because I got to start my job okay great
and then I book an Uber and there he is
a total fluke but amazing and so it's a
lot of work you know I was all day all
night not connecting with my team not
doing the things that I'm supposed to be
doing and I still make time to be with
people and and make a one hour meet up
because that hour was open and
it fuels me but if it was something that
I hated just that half an hour just 15
minutes I'd start to feel like I'm
burning out like I don't want to be here
this is terrible and so I think it's
really important that you're doing work
that you love that would be a burnout
for other people but not a burnout for
you because you love it so much so how
do you find it how do you find the work
that you love I got a three-step process
called who I how I'm going to talk about
it in depth in my next book but let's do
a super quick analysis here to help you
guys who might be struggling step number
one is who so you're who is your most
important core value what is your most
important core value as a human being
mine is believe it's a one word most
important core value for me so when you
figure out what it is that you stand for
as a human you can then look at your
life and see where you're falling short
if you are unhappy with life it's
because you are living incongruently
with your most important core value so
someone whose core value is freedom as
an example
you can look at your life like are you
allowed to be free are you free at work
are you free in your relationships are
you free you know in these different
areas if not then you're not going to be
happy that's why you're not happy
because your boss doesn't allow you to
have freedom mine is believe so believe
has to be in everything that I touch if
there's a situation that's lacking
believe I'm not going to be happy with
it so that just gives you a radio
indication of who you are and starts to
make sense of your life going backwards
and allows you to plan it better going
forward so it's one of the most
important exercises I think anybody can
do figure out what your who is who I
have step two is why so why is your
purpose your purpose comes in your pain
your purpose comes from the deepest
darkest most painful moment in your life
whatever that was your purpose is to
help other people who are currently
going through that thing whatever you
struggled with suffered with endured
felt like you never want to wish that on
your worst enemy never want to go back
and experience again that pain that's
what I'm talking about you want to help
other people who are currently going
through that pain because there's a lot
of people who are currently going
through that thing who you were X number
of years ago there's a lot of people who
are currently like that right now that's
who you want to help for Life that'll
never get old that's your purpose for
life I want to help entrepreneurs for
life I believe in entrepreneurs for life
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur and I want to make the path
a little bit easier for everybody else
so that's your why and you're who and
your why are constant they never change
your core values and your purpose are
for life and that's amazing the last
step is how who I how how is your
passion how is how you got out of the
pain that you're in so you struggled
with something how did you get out of it
you may not be fully out of it maybe
you're still on your journey out of it
but you're further ahead than you used
to be how did you get out of it did you
read books did you watch videos did you
meditate did you walk your dogs did you
listen to music like how did you get out
of it how did you get out of it and that
is a recipe that you can teach other
people how you got out of it was not
some random one-off situation you can
teach other people so I struggled a lot
with my business I felt worthless as a
human I wanted to quit I told my partner
that I quit how I got out of it was
modeling success I looked at Bill Gates
how he started Microsoft and I applied
those strategies to my business and we
started to see some success 20 years
later what am I doing still modeling
success right I want to learn from Grant
I want to learn from Steve I want to
learn from Kanye I want to learn from
these people it's why keep creating this
content how I got out of it was studying
success and now I teach other people how
to study success
right how you actually go about doing it
may change when I first started doing it
20 years ago is through books right now
it's through videos and in 10 years 20
years is going to be through VR and a
bunch of other technologies that I'm
sure are coming but the how you got out
is a teachable recipe that you can give
to other people so if you're struggling
with burnout
and you think it's because you don't
love the work that you're doing and you
know that you're destined for something
greater that you do have Michael Jordan
level talented something but you don't
know what it is and you want to figure
it out figure it out this is this is the
process this is the easiest process I
know of to get there figure out your who
your one where most important core value
figure out your why your purpose comes
in your pain and figure out your how
which is your passion how you got out of
it you can teach other people and that
will set you up for an amazing life with
hopefully very little burnout and
definitely a lot of purpose be the
change you want to see in the world
one of my favorite quotes Mahatma Gandhi
if you're not happy with something
you're not happy with a situation you
fix it that's why entrepreneurs are
going to solve all the problems
as much as the government and big
business I think it's entrepreneurs it's
us we're going to solve all the world's
problems because we see a problem and we
want to fix it we want to solve it
that's what we do that's the most
exciting part of being an entrepreneur
is that you're not waking up and driving
to some job that you hate where the work
you're doing does not matter has no
meaning and instead you get to do
something that is actually going to
touch somebody's life and that is
Meaningful to you right you get the pick
you get to decide you get to choose and
we're trying to make the world a better
place we're going to make money doing it
too but Mission first purpose first and
then making money along the way in
service of others and it's in that
combination of what you love doing with
what brings value to other people that
you have a successful business
part of that then becomes being a leader
as well and I think a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle with being the
leader because at the beginning
we are just managing ourselves and
that's hard enough right it's like have
you had a hard time managing yourself
have you had a hard time sticking to
your routines and keeping to your
motivation and staying strong and the
things that you say you're going to do
like self-management self-leadership is
hard enough now we're going to go off
and lead other people as well and where
do we learn about leadership we don't go
to school for this we don't have
programs we don't probably have great
mentors to help us if you had jobs in
the past or maybe you're at a job right
now you probably don't have the greatest
leaders around you most people suck at
it
but it doesn't have to be
extremely difficult
and it took me a long time to get used
to it and get better at it and I'm still
learning and improving we've got almost
40 people on the team now and can people
ask me what's my definition my
definition of leadership it's I want
people to win more than I want them to
win with me
and so the key becomes
wanting the humans that are on your team
to win as humans
more than you want them to win with you
that you can have this little
disconnection obviously they have to do
the work if they're going to work with
you but sometimes the best thing for
them to do is to move on
not because they're not doing their job
but because it's the best thing for them
and so when I connect with the people on
my team it's always trying to figure out
where do they want to go what do they
want to learn what do they what do they
want to improve on and I see everybody
as running parallel paths with me so the
people around you the people even us
right now what we're doing right now
this is a parallel path you've decided
to watch this video I decided to record
this video and we're sharing this moment
in time and maybe you never watch
another Urban Carmichael video again
maybe you end up watching all my videos
and we end up being Partners on some
future business who knows you know we
haven't seen you every day in the future
but as of right now we're on this
parallel path together and
when somebody's with you walking down
that parallel path
the goal of a great leader I think
should be to try to make that person
leave better than how they came in
right have you ever heard the expression
um my grandfather used to tell me about
you know when you go to a hotel
or you go to a new city or you go to a
new event they always try to leave the
place better than when you came
you know and hopefully that's our goal
for life you know in this life we try to
leave
the world a little better than how it
was when we came in
and so if you take that approach to
leadership that when you're with the
people on your team
and maybe it's for a week on some really
short internship maybe it's for a year
maybe it's for five years ten years
maybe it's their entire life with you
that they have left a little bit better
than when they came in because they got
to hang around you and not taking it as
an ego play like I'm gonna make this
person's life better because I am so
amazing it's more out of care
genuine care
for the people on your team and I think
when we're first hiring
we suck at it
most entrepreneurs suck at hiring most
entrepreneurs their first employee is
not with them you know a year two years
three years later because they hired the
wrong person they have no idea how to
manage that person it's not that that
person sucks it's more that you know you
don't have the skill set we don't have
the skill sets at the beginning to know
how to even find the right person let
alone manage them and so
you know we that's the skill that we
have to develop but I think it just
starts with genuinely caring about the
people on your team that yes they have
to get the work done right there's a job
that has to get done but how we often
think about it is more from a selfish
perspective as I need to get this stuff
off my plate right you're overloaded
with work right who's over are you
overloaded with work we're overloaded
with work
so I gotta hire somebody to take this
off my plate so I don't have to deal
with that ever again and it frees up my
time to go and do other stuff
right so familiar listen at the
beginning when you bring on team it
takes more time
it takes more time than it frees up
because you have to train them you have
to listen to them you have to care for
them you have to answer their questions
if you treat them like a robot or a
monkey
they're not going to stick with you
you're going to constantly be hiring and
firing and hiring firing you're going to
be massively frustrated and overwhelmed
and a lot of a lot of entrepreneurs get
stuck in that cycle where has this
happened to you you hire somebody you
know looks great on paper you're so
excited for it to go and then it doesn't
work out a couple months later and then
you decide you know what I'm just gonna
do it all myself right I know I can get
it done I'm just gonna do it on myself
does that happen to you
that is not the path to building a
movement you know you can have a great
little solo business for yourself but
that's not how you change the world
that's not how you realize your
potential it's not how you have the
impact that you know you're capable of
having you know you have to have people
around you if you've got a big mission
if you don't have a big mission that's
just it's just you cool go for it but if
you've got a big mission then it needs
to be team and that becomes a skill set
that you have to pick up and learn
and so leadership for me is again caring
about people as humans more than caring
about them winning with you it's about
discovering what they want to learn and
grow and improve at and you being a
vehicle to help them do that
and it's surprising how often you can
find things that support them and
support you not all the time I remember
having one guy in my team who his dream
was to be a baker
like well I I don't have an interest in
opening up a bake shop right but
ultimately you should you should leave
us and go do your passion because
because I can't help you inside of this
job
until I open a bake shop that can really
support you in what you want to do and
so even though he wanted to stay he was
staying more out of fear and insecurity
than actually doing something he was
deeply passionate about so I gave him
till the end of the year if it was you
know summer give him to the end of the
year to okay you're as of the end of the
year you you're out and you have to go
find a job I love you but you have to go
find something that is
in line with your dream because you
staying here is is safe and it's
actually squashing your dreams
you have to go do your thing and so you
know you had to go and move on it was
appreciative for it and giving him time
not like okay you're fired next week
and then you have other people though
and usually you can find something
inside of what they care about so the
the amount of people who I've met on my
team who then they want to learn graphic
design or they want to learn Photoshop
or they want to learn uh copywriting or
they want to learn how to come up with
good titles or they want to learn
better communication skills or they want
to learn they have their lists of like
the things that they want to learn
it's like cool as long as there's
something that we've got
that can help you with that some kind of
program some project something that can
also bring value to the company then
let's do it because when people are
working on the things that they feel
like they're growing in and they're
learning in
they're gonna
it's just a good thing to do because
it's it's from the heart you know and
when they feel connected to your heart
everybody's happier and more productive
but it's also just good business
strategy if you want to just put your
Exo business strategy hat on it's it's
great this is how Karma becomes
practical if somebody's engaged and they
feel like they're learning and they're
growing and they're improving you're
going to get the best of them versus you
have to feel bored and stuck and
learning nothing new right that's what
most people do in their jobs and
honestly the bar for leadership is so
low
it's so low most people wake up and
drive to that job that they hate so all
you have to do to be honest to be their
best boss is probably just to not be a
bad boss you don't have to be a great
boss you just have to not not be a bad
boss you need to treat somebody like a
normal human being and actually have a
little bit of care and compassion and
curiosity to see them win in life
you do that you're already probably
their best boss of all time I think
that's a pretty low standard but it's a
great starting point
to then be able to say hey no I want I
want this person to have come out of my
organization whether that's in a month
or year 10 years from now a better human
because they were with us and it's
totally possible
it's just a mindset shift
that
these people are on your team
because they have something to prove as
well and they want to learn and it's not
just about you saving your time and
dumping stuff off of your plate and
giving it to somebody else so it can be
all delegated away
it's that you are a leader
and you care about people
you want to see them win and you're
responsible
for making sure that they get pushed
outside their comfort zone
you got a big mission inside you
a huge mission
and you can't do this alone
and you may not have the skills yet
to be the leader that you want to be
maybe not yet
but you've got a big heart
and honestly
that's the biggest skill that you ever
need your energy changes how you show up
when you are happy positive optimistic
full of life Creative Energy you you
make amazing things
but when you feel negative down
depressed side for yourself low energy
you know you don't make amazing things
and this is not something new that I'm
telling you you know this
the challenges we are not in a high
energy state
consistently enough to stay consistent
on our goals so follow through to create
the momentum because we allow outside
forces as well as our internal voice to
keep us small to keep us protected to
keep us scared to depress our courage
muscle
and then even though you have great
ideas and great Ambitions and a great
heart and a desire to serve it doesn't
happen doesn't happen because
the energy isn't connected to it if
you've got
a big idea
but low energy
nothing happens
you don't follow through and you end up
seeing other people
with a worse version of your idea but
just more energy and go off and do it
have you ever seen that happen you ever
seen somebody
make tons of money have a huge impact
off of your idea but somebody with less
heart and less vision and less
creativity but they just they just did
it they just got started they just took
action it just stayed consistent in
their energy and they made it happen and
you didn't because you allowed the
energy to dip
and so if energy is so important then
how do we how do we manage your energy
how do we keep it high and doesn't mean
that you always have to be on top of the
world and you don't have to delude
yourself and say I'm amazing this is
going to be the greatest day of all time
like you don't
doing things that you don't believe
won't help you get the energy that you
need because you'll do those things say
This is BS this isn't working
you don't always have to be in Peak
energy
but what you didn't need to do is be in
the right energy to serve your mission
and whatever you're doing today so let
me use me as an example and today
uh it's a great example because I did
not sleep well last night had had two
and a half hours sleep just tossing and
turning and and just could not
could not get to sleep so I slept from
like 6 30 to 9 o'clock did not sleep
until 6 30 in the morning
and that is thankfully a rare occurrence
you know most nights I get eight hours
sleep seven and a half to eight and a
half hours sleep
but
on a day like today when I woke up and
did not have a ton of energy I did not
wake up and say yes I feel like crushing
it let's go and
I didn't want to do something that would
feel fake and disingenuous because if
you don't believe it then it's not going
to happen anyway so what did I do well
first off videos have to happen today
because that's part of my identity right
so momentum has to happen
so if you start to train yourself and
you create a calendar and say okay today
is a blank I'm filming this on a Tuesday
today's a Tuesday Tuesday's my video day
no matter what I'm filming videos I
gotta film videos it's got to happen it
may not be my best video
but I'm going to show up and give it my
the best that I've got the best energy
this is this is a lot lower energy than
I would normally show up with a video
but it's a different vibe it's a
different kind of energy and hopefully
it still serves and maybe maybe you like
and connect more with this energy then
I've been yelling in the car I don't
know but videos have to happen first off
second get outside
you know get outside get fresh air get
some sun on my face if you you know you
want to change your energy you want to
shift where you're at and how you're
thinking because it's part physical
energy but also just mental energy how
do you feel about what you're doing and
what's going to happen today and getting
out of your home changing your physical
environment and getting some sun on your
face
can make a huge difference so every
morning I have my believe walk and I'm
walking around the park getting some
green getting some sun hopefully it's
not raining today's a beautiful day and
everybody it starts to make you feel a
little bit happier a little bit more in
the right energy space
music is a great way to change your
energy and often what we do is we put on
songs that make us feel how we currently
are so if you feel sad you put on a sad
song If you feel low you put on a low
song and you feel chill you put on a
Chill song
where what we want to do is if you want
to change your energy put on the song
that matches that energy
if you want to feel happier upbeat put
unhappy or beat songs I have a playlist
on my channel called hashtag believe all
caps on the on the letters believe
that's all the songs that I listen to
and every day I've got that playlist
going I pick a random song and it just
starts playing and they're all songs
that if they came on it would make me
move
and when you move you start to change
your energy
what I'm trying to do is again not
create some fake energy but something I
can actually connect with I'm putting on
songs that I actually like I actually
like having some sunshine on my face you
know I actually like doing the work I'm
about to do
but it requires you showing up with a
certain level of energy
and then the last one is
you know who you're feeding your mind
with who are you around who you're
surrounded by both the people in your
life you know actual humans
and the videos that you watch or books
that you read and podcasts you consume I
remember on the weekend
you gotta guard against this it's crazy
so on the weekend I went to go
meets an old family friend
and
he just had
a lot of limiting
beliefs about him and what he's creating
and where he wants to go and it wasn't
it wasn't meant to be a coaching session
I'm not there to help him but just a
really negative low energy on a weekend
and I'm you know that's not usually part
of my routine on the weekend and so I go
to meet him
and my whole day ended up being thrown
off until I caught it at night to say
why why am I so low and negative today
in comparison to what I would normally
be and I thought back like oh yeah you
know what ever since I went to see him I
was fine in the morning I went to see
him and had this negative ripple effect
you know like you could have a positive
ripple effect on people you watch a
video and it can have a positive ripple
effect on you but but there's negative
Ripple effects too
and the people who you're surrounded by
who you're hanging out with or you're
watching on YouTube or podcasts Etc they
can have a negative ripple effect on you
as well
and so he had this
negative ripple effect on me that lasted
almost the whole day until I caught it
in the evening said this isn't what I
want
it's not even my voice it's like his
voice planted in me why am I feeling
this
being this way I don't like it
and so it became a conscious choice and
I applied a lot of the same things I got
it I went outside went outside reset get
some fresh air it always helps me put on
some music songs that I actually like
not some fake song that somebody else
likes and says dance to this it'll make
you feel good as long as I actually like
there are some songs that if it came on
it would
make you move it doesn't mean you get up
and dance and go [ __ ] and crazy but
there's some songs that have came on you
you would Bob your head or you would tap
your feet or bounce your knee there's
some songs that just make you do that
right so put on one of those songs it
would naturally make you feel happier
so I did that too and then in terms of
just gardening against people I made a
note that hey the next time I go see
this person he's a he's a family friend
so the next time I go see him
which is not often but still the next
time I see him I need to remind myself
of this
you know that that I need to I need to
have my shield ready
I need to give love as much as possible
and I'm not going to allow his
negativity to to break my shield you
know to permeate through
and so the more that you can catch those
things
the more you'll stay in a more energetic
state
and all of this again is not trying to
force fake energy and have you feel like
you're doing something unnatural I think
it's actually the most natural thing of
all time I think getting sun is natural
I think smiling and being optimistic is
natural I think everything I think the
negativity inside your head was planted
there was put there by other people
that's what's unnatural when you were a
kid and smiling and happy had dreams for
the future everything was possible
everything was hopeful
sure we had bad days but you were a
happy kid
and all of those dreams and positivity
get squashed out of us by other people
who hate their lives and so I think
having energy is actually the most
natural thing not every day has to be on
top of the world but
having positive energy is natural having
Sunshine leading to happiness is natural
putting on music and and dancing and
moving is natural
being around other positive optimistic
happy people when you're around them
you'll naturally be more positive
optimistic and happy and so it's about
finding what is a natural flow for you
that when you do these things
it brings out a better energy in you
it brings out a happier more positive
more optimistic you and if you know what
some of those things are
you can copy my list if you want some of
them right sunshine music videos
then put into your daily routine
put into your daily calendar every day
this has to happen
because if you did the thing just
imagine this you've had days when you
felt energetic and you've had days when
you didn't and every would everybody
would give you the the out right like a
day like today two and a half hours
sleep
everybody would give me the I was like
it's okay you don't have to do it
there are days when you need to bring
the energy
if you did that every day
just imagine for the next month every
day you did the thing that puts you in a
better energy state
I thought you're on top of the world and
the fake high every day but a better
energy state
you did the thing in the morning that
put you in a better energy State for the
next 30 days how much is your life
change
how much is how you show up change how
much is the work that you do change how
much does your bank account change how
much is the impact you're creating
change how much of a better father or
mother or husband or wife are you
because you're showing up with more
energy more positive energy focus on one
idea and make it work focus on one
business model focus on one Revenue
stream focus on one social media Network
and make it work so many times we're
focused on too many things we're
distracted and our entrepreneur ADHD
kicks in and as a result nothing happens
for all the people who are telling you
to have 13 different passive income
streams because if one goes away you
still have all these other 12. most
people who start off doing that make
zero money from all of the passive
income streams you're making ten dollars
a month four dollars a month seven
dollars a month where instead if you
could focus on one thing
and maximize it and make it amazing and
put your energy into it you will see
exponential results I look at social
media as an example and I just finished
this training where we did the seven day
built to serve challenge it was amazing
had so many awesome new thought leaders
coming to the program people got a big
message want to serve and one of the
questions I kept getting asking is
how do I be on every social media
platform how do I be everywhere how do I
get started and just blow up everywhere
and it's like you don't right the
answers don't don't don't try to do that
if you are the person right now who is
trying to be everywhere look at your
social media accounts
chances are you're sucking everywhere
chances are not not you suck as a human
just the results aren't there the
effort's not there the energy is not
there because you're so forcing yourself
to just get out there and create content
and be in all the platforms
that you also have a million other
things that you have to do and so as a
result you're you're creating
really mediocre content
content that people aren't interacting
with and if people don't like what
you're putting up it's not going to lead
to results for your business and so much
much much much much better it doesn't
mean that you can't be there you know it
doesn't mean that at some point you
can't be there that as you build your
brand and you get bigger and you hire a
team and you have more money that you
can start to do this but much better at
the beginning is to figure out
what is the one platform what is the one
Revenue stream what is the one business
model the one thing that if I focus on
that thing
it's going to lead to results so then I
can scale
entrepreneurs have a hard time with this
because we want to do so many things we
have our add brain going on and
we don't want to just do one thing we
also feel like it
is limiting for what we want to do right
if you have a big Vision a big mission a
giant goal for what you want to
accomplish
doing just this one little piece of it
feels too small
the way that I would structure it and
think about it is this is just a
sequence
you still get to do everything
you still get to do it all
you just have to go in order you have to
create a sequence that the thing that
you need to focus on at the beginning of
your business whether it's your Revenue
stream whether it's a social media
success whatever it is what you have to
figure out is how do I start to as soon
as possible get a sustainable business
for myself
so that I can quit my job if you have
one so that I can bring income in for
myself my family so I can start to
afford to hire a team even if it's
part-time or one person so you can scale
up your company so that I can then go
off and do all the other things because
some of your ideas are are amazing and
huge and require more people and time
and effort and energy and some of the
ideas can get started a lot faster
and so if you want to go and accomplish
your big goal your big dream your big
mission then it's important to think
about the sequence of things that
instead of doing everything all at once
and as a result all of the results being
mediocre focus on the one thing that if
you push that lever you really maximize
that thing
you could start to make more money you
could start to have more impact you can
start to have more reach you can start
to see more success that then allows you
to bring on more people to help you
build and scale
for me we've got 37 people on the team
now
and
I can do so much more you know because
we got team then if it was just me by
myself doing everything and so in
building my mission I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right people
don't believe in themselves enough and
so in building that up I need people I
need help I need support I need team I
need I need a lot more than what I've
got right now
but and be able to build a business that
can bring in money then I can afford the
higher team that helps me accomplish a
lot more things and take on a lot more
projects but if I was at the very
beginning of what I was doing right now
I would not be doing most of the things
that I'm doing right now
I'd still be accomplishing and going
after the same mission
but I'd have to pick one thing to focus
on
I think the one thing at the beginning
that I think I could make some money
doing this so that I can live I can I
can pay you know rent mortgage
I can pay my internet bills I could pay
for some food not not living you know
fancy light but just being able to live
and survive so I don't have to have a
job and then I would start thinking okay
how do I then scale this one thing that
I'm working on
to build up to the point where I can
remove myself or at least take some of
the pieces off so that I can hire a team
to help build and scale and grow if I
look back at my YouTube Journey here I
did everything at the beginning you know
I I uh I filmed it I researched it I
edited it I did all of it and it took a
crazy amount of time and I made a lot of
mistakes and I did a lot of stuff that I
probably shouldn't have done and
just by focusing on that thing and
making content and creating videos it
then allowed me to make a little bit of
money that then I could hire my first
part-time editor that then turned into a
full-time editor that turned into a
second editor and a research person that
turned into someone helping with the
thumbnails and the graphics and it
continues to build up in scale but
everything I was doing myself in a
mediocre way but getting it done
to then be able to scale out a team and
so most people are just stuck doing too
many things you start look at what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis look
at your calendar you have a limited
amount of time right you have a limited
amount of time there's only so much you
can do in in a day in a week you have
other responsibilities maybe you have a
job maybe you have family kids health
that you have to look after you know
there's a certain amount of time that
you have that you can dedicate to this
thing that time needs to go into the
right efforts
and again it's great to have that big
mission and big goal and big dream but
if you have a limited amount of time
every day or every week
and you are
trying to create 13 passive income
streams with that limited amount of time
no one of the streams ever gets enough
energy enough effort Enough of Your Mind
space enough of your creativity Enough
of Your Love to ever become anything
and so you're diversifying way too
quickly you're diversifying way too soon
and apply that for anything that you're
working on apply that to your your
business and the and the opportunities
that you're chasing the Partnerships
that you're looking at the things that
you're saying yes to the social media
networks that you're trying to be on
do yourself a favor
don't try to be everywhere not yet
right just understand there's a sequence
to things and you can make it so much
easier for yourself to have more impact
to make more money to have a bigger
influence to be more proud of yourself
to start getting more success and more
results and more momentum so much easier
if you just sequence it out
so that you don't have to do everything
all at once you don't have to feel the
the handcuffs and the Restriction of
saying well I don't want to do this one
thing for the rest of my life this is
where it gets
you know entrepreneur Ade kicks in right
and we don't want to be locked in I
don't want to do the same thing forever
well you don't you won't do it forever
that's not the point
the point is not to do this one thing
forever that if you took these 10
opportunities in front of you
you could do all 10. you could do all
10.
just not all 10 at the same time because
if you do all 10 at the same time none
of them are going to work out
and often it's a small opportunity that
can pay you more quickly
that can start to build the momentum for
you so if you have your list of your 10
opportunities in front of you 10 things
that you could do great look at what
order should I go in
so I can start making money and start
building momentum one last quick example
I look at a lot of thought leaders a lot
of people have a message a lot of people
want to be speakers and authors and
coaches and influencers and
they've got big goals and big Ambitions
for what they want to create
when I'm helping someone like that
usually the first option is coaching
the best thing to do at the beginning is
coaching so we're going to dive into one
specific business model right if you can
look at let's say be a speaker
uh getting brand deals as an influencer
writing a book and coaching if we had
those are four opportunities in front of
you right let's say so what did I say
being a speaker getting paid to speak
getting paid to do brand deals getting
paid to be an author and selling books
um even selling courses your own
materials and training and Etc and
coaching
those are those are you know four or
five different business models that you
can go through perfect
at the beginning
which one is the best
what should you focus on
coaching
why
people don't like the idea of coaching
because you're trading your time for
money right I don't want to trade my
time for money okay
well what are you doing right now you
know you're at a job because if you're
at a job you're trading your time for
money
if you have unlimited time to figure
stuff out and you have you have a giant
bank account then you could do something
different but if you need to start to
make money to build this thing up then
yes you're trading your time for money
but it's a faster path to get you out of
your job and into your business
full-time
where everything else takes a lot more
time
speaking takes an incredible amount of
time if you want to if you want to be a
paid speaker and and get paid enough
that it's actually meaningful
it takes a lot of time for you to get
good at the skill as well as for you to
build up momentum and a name in the
industry you have to do a lot of free
speaking gigs before you ever get paid
to do it so if you have a horizon of
years awesome but I'd rather you start
get paid immediately while we work on
the speaking career you want to be an
author and get paid to have a book cool
you can go and sell publish a book right
now if you wanted to you can get it out
you'll make you know you can sell it to
your friends and family your your
audience you'll make a a few bucks but
it's not going to be anything meaningful
to get a paid deal or to have a
significant even if you're going
self-publishing to make a lot of money
off your book you have to have a big
audience
to get the deal with a publisher they
want you to have at least a hundred
thousand followers that's like your
starting point to get in so is that
achievable of course but now we're
looking at years as a horizon as opposed
to like this has to happen right away so
you're not getting paid right now off of
your book so if you're sitting there
thinking right in the book creating a
great manuscript creating a great how-to
guide it's not going to be the thing
that helps get you any kind of money
anytime soon and I want you to get paid
because most people quit too soon on
their ideas or they're trying to do a
million different things at once right
if you're trying to create a course
same thing you have to build up enough
momentum you spend so much time making a
course creating the content filming
videos or writing instruction manuals or
creating the PDFs or whatever your
course structure is it takes so long to
make the course
and then you have to go and Market the
course and people don't know who you are
yet people you don't have a brand yet so
could it work absolutely will it pay you
more than coaching yes absolutely most
likely it's way more easy to leverage
that than coaching
but again the timeline is so long
and most people quit too soon on it
where if you were coaching you can you
can make money right away as long as you
have something that can actually help
people right if you're good at what you
do you know how to solve somebody's
problem you can make money as a coach
right away and yes you're trading your
time for money but it's better than
having a job and it also gets you closer
to your customers at the very beginning
that much I'm a much bigger fan of
selling a service than a product because
it gets you closer to your customers you
get to know their problems you know
their issues you know what exactly
they're struggling with and you can help
them solve it which allows you to create
a better book a better course a better
product because you've worked with
enough people through the problem
and so
most entrepreneurs fall into the
category I want to do all of it great I
want to be a speaker I want to be an
author I want to create my course I want
to create my book I want to be a coach I
want to do all of it awesome you have a
limited amount of time every week
to work on all five of those things at
the same time means there's very little
progress how if that's you and you've
been writing your book how long you've
written your book for
you're like when is it going to come out
what year
how many speaking gigs have you done in
the past three months
all right how much time has gone into
your course it's like we start and stop
and start and stop because we're
tackling so many different things
because you want to do it all and you
want to have income streams coming in
like crazy and there's nothing wrong
with that it's amazing but there's a
sequence
there's an order
that if you can as soon as possible
inside of your purpose
start to make money start to build
momentum start to be able to bring on
team to help you it's so much easier you
can go so much further you can go so
much faster you can have so much less
stress
you can have such a big impact
that you just need to focus
you just need to focus
it's all possible your big dreams are
possible
go in order figure out the sequence that
will start to get you paid
Focus
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there the fastest way to accomplish
anything is to model someone who has
already had the same success that you
are after you can go around trying to
figure out everything by yourself trying
to come up with every new idea yourself
and you will slowly